it was an emotional blitz of super bowl
ads last night I cried over a few over
all the commercials beard away from the
funny and Goofy and towards the serious
and somber Budweiser played up puppy
love nationwide addressed child safety
if you can say that and dove took on
fatherhood the restraining really joins
me now for a look at the commercials
okay me dejan i wish i can but like this
commercial me cry I can't even i watch
that I counted Alex 4.5 dad themed ads
last night about what it is to be a debt
and that one in particular just broke my
heart that's just not even fair and at
the end there's just sort of thrown in
you know dove and I think that the the
marketing incentive to go towards dad is
obviously a huge football demographic
but we also know that adds that resonate
emotionally will play for a long time
after the Super Bowl so it's a good way
to get attention but it seems like a lot
of the product placement was just kind
of casually thrown in at the end like
Nissan Nissan did this long ad about an
absentee father who couldn't be bothered
to raise his son because he was so busy
racing cars there by the way yeah
exactly exactly and then in the end it's
okay cuz he shows up and he's driving a
Nissan I'm really confused by this I was
really confused by the nationwide ad
obviously everyone hated it you know you
ended with a dead child that was a
terrible terrible image however that was
all Twitter talked about for 16 minutes
and the spoofs off of the nationwide ad
we're all a twitter which made me kind
of wonder does it matter whether or not
your ad is good or bad or just that
you're talking about i think so i think
godaddy has learned that you can make a
tasteless add people talk about it
forever but nationwide that was a little
weird because insurers have an interest
in risk mitigation and public service
that's sort of part of their image but
this really felt totally wrong and
awkward to me I you know I like thinking
about catching my kids in the pool and
not about having them die totally fair
yeah talk about as it actually worked
because you talk to an analyst on
balance it doesn't mean this because we
found it entertaining means that it
actually got so ray Katz his favorite
had absolutely was a wix had a bunch of
former NFL stars make their favorite
websites favre and carve Franco Harris's
immaculate receptions these are web
based businesses he said the rate cast
is the analyst from Columbia University
said it was a perfect blocking and
tackling just launching your Brad brand
using NFL stars during the Super Bowl
alright thanks Brendon I love it i'm
going to talk about commercials all day
long bloomberg's brendan really